Tap,
yes or no,
yes.
The future linaricenter City Hall Center engross,
yes or no?
Yes,
which language model do you choose?
A,
b or d?
D
would be in favor of 1 wind farm
in your municipality of residence?
Yes.
What do you prioritize,
sovereignty?
B,
care or c,
economy,
care and economics
cell phones?
At the Cole you have to paint them,
they must be regulated.
Do you consider that Donostia
need 1 new multipurpose pavilion?
I think so.
It would deduct the home purchase deduction.
To encourage renting,
It would probably lower the equality.
Considers that parity quotas should be established
in the executives of the parties,
of course.
And finally,
Do you have private or health insurance,
don't you?